Question, what do you recommend for immune support for kids who are prone to allergies,
ear infections, and sinus infections? So, depending on the age of the child,
testing can be done as well. Again, it sounds like a broken record, but, okay, let's say by
two-year-old, this gets ear infections and allergies on a regular basis, and I've run it
with repeated nutrition in there. Give me the antibiotics. First of all, 99.9 percent of
ear infections are not bacterial based. So, taking an antibiotic is just doing more harm than good,
you're just damaging the gut and the flora throughout the whole body. You just highly don't
recommend that. Unless you tested, unless you did a blood test, and you had elevated white blood cells,
and elevated neutrophils, and suppressed lymphocytes, then you'd say, okay, this person has an
infection, and doing an antibiotic is the right course of care. But if they just looked at the
ear and say, oh, you have an ear infection, here's the antibiotics. That's just, that's just
about practice. That's just wrong. So, don't do that. There's reasons why. So, I always dig into the
reason why, right? So, if a child has irregular ear infections, you start thinking of what's your
comment was on this question. Does this child have allergies? Most common thing for regular ear
infections, regular sinus infections are food-based, not environmental-based. Unless the child, you know,
getting a good history is important, right? So, oh, I only get these in the spreadwood
pollen is flying. And I get ear infections, I get allergies and sinus infections. Well, it's
probably that environmental-based and something like pollen or something. But if know this happens
throughout the winter, where there's no pollen in the air, then it's probably food-based or chemical-based.
So, a sensitivity to most common, what would it be? Gluten and dairy, most common, right off the back.
So, if they have a gluten or dairy sensitivity, that means if they have antibodies to gliannid
in any of the gliannid peptides, or they have antibodies to k-seed, you're just going to be,
they're eating that stuff. You're just causing inflammation. K-seed especially is going to be very
mucus-forming, and there's the problem, most likely. You could also have antibodies to
chemicals in the environment. The most common would be food-based, but definitely chemicals in the
environment, from fluoride to mercury to a whole bunch of different things could be things that
set it off as well. So, anytime a person has antibodies to foods that's causing the issue,
and then they just get tipped over by pollen or something like that. So, really pollen is the
primary thing. That's just what tips them over. So, they're already so near the threshold
of a hyper-inflammatory response, and then spilling out the increased mucus formation, and then they
end up with other symptoms. So, what did you do for that? You have to investigate. You have to find out
what is the thing that is causing the inflammatory response. So, putting on your Sherlock Holmes hat,
if the kids are too little to do a blood test, and just start doing some food elimination diet.
So, again, most common would be dairy and gluten. It could be followed by dyes and additives,
calories, glyphosates, chemicals in the food. That's going to be your most common thing is food-based,
food sources. So, clean up the diet, go organic as much as possible.
Kids that have this, even if they cut away down a dairy and gluten, they would have a decrease
of their symptoms. So, look at that.